it's not about control standing it's a  relationship based on respect these  animals are thinking I got to eat  I got you got to be able to relate to at  least one of those things every time  we've unveiled a new attraction  attendance spiked  corporate felt genetic classification  without the wow factor they're dinosaurs  while we're not she was designed to be  bigger than the t-rex what happened to  the sibling she ate it  we have an asset out of containment  what is that the tracking implant she  clawed about how would it know to do  that  she remembered when they put it in she's  killing for sport  you got a 20,000 people you got no more  votes  don't have enough guns if we do this we  do this my way  your eyes on target light it up  is wrong communicating here  a highly intelligent animal